hey you guys I'm Lisa from the score
eSports and we are here in sunny
Barcelona to wrap up 2016 now it's been
an exciting year of csgo so here are
your top 10 best plays of the year to
kill this game just keeps on giving
you dumped 25
try to piece that together coach they
need to get all hang on he's finished
the job II started takes down cold first
off that's kinetics we're losing
two-plus players and a lot of rounds
here and it's lost its appeal in the
late stages here for TSM but criminis I
[Music]
don't know what to say
come on the fight
[Music]
there have been as well
Oh Crim's that is fully disgusting there
what are we witnessing now near the last
one left no one on for Dignitas
resigning it easily Falls VP with just
sat in positions when no one was
watching the fountain neo Marie nearly
last a second will through the wall and
now with this smoke he can get the bomb
planted the problem is think this house
have a lot of grenades still up there
neo because he has a Molotov and I bet
he would love to use to the buying time
but they've already smoked down the form
there's another headshot coming through
he'd have to go over the age punch into
winning the semi-finals here looking for
another spray
right into the crunch does find one
leave him out of this the Big Apple and
snacks is hungry he's got one kill
already of the USB which he is well on
Daugherty and inflamed he is trying to
beat them out trying to get me to
one-on-one to be danced back and forth
between the bars so much
Guardian bye-bye
[Music]
right and this is characteristically
picking up the beagle mist around
let's go finding a shot or two three
that's the difference and now they know
that the man is behind yellow as well
twist will fight back with Nico still
alive he's still kicking and he finds
another one for head shots for Nico in
the pistol we're in the whippin a shot
there's the second though now again as
we seen so many times before it's down
the heater but against four is it really
possible you do have a beautiful is
quite tagged up here from luminosity so
he chose Fe not going down without a
fight
all one there's the first part right
here go gets a double there's still two
players left thing on though help open
thirteen and three Kiko around the side
now this this time it's all my goodness
how does he do this how does he go do it
again
privately are censoring they dating off
the jail vehicle lansinoh shot really
fully away goes to check the window this
is all about timing
nitro does have a lot of another smoker
could be really rough
[Music]
I need to drop
what is that it going to go simple
names for committee bucks want you to
listen to work with he really comes once
again the first base is a trendy hit the
ground
and there you have it do you agree with
our list
or do you feel like we missed something
let us know in the comments below
I'm Lisa from the score eSports and
we'll see you guys next year
[Music]